the white house spinning faster than
biden's peloton after being forced to
negotiate with taliban terrorists the
group allowed 200 americans and other
foreigners to fly at kabul kabul
whatever today after biden stranded them
there the pentagon even calling the
terrorists
like while americans are still stuck
there in gensake trying to claim this
was the plan all along
you're saying the taliban is
businesslike and professional their
interior minister has an fbi wanted
poster he's got a 10 million dollar
bounty on his head that's
what's the business
we are here to celebrate the return of
american citizens who wanted to leave
afghanistan of legal permanent residents
of afghans who fought by our side to cut
her successfully on a cuttery airlines
flight and in order to get those people
out we had to work with some members of
the taliban to press them
and to work in a business-like manner to
get them out that is what we were
stating in the statement in that
statement it says this is a positive
first step towards what
towards getting additional people out
who want to leave afghanistan so judge
this segment explains the previous
segment every time you approach the the
issue of afghanistan you see the
incompetence you see their horrible
implementation the worst the worst
foreign policy
action you've seen in recent lifetime
that is why we had the a-block that's
right that's right that's why we have
the a-block and you know with the best
part of this is they're saying when
you're talking about the six charter
planes that are stuck in the northern
part of the country they say you know we
couldn't get those out we couldn't get
those planes out because we don't have
people on the ground well why don't we
have people on the ground we don't have
people on the ground because we had all
the military leave before the people
left and yet they're over there
celebrating and thanking the taliban who
knows how much money they they paid them
who knows how much they've agreed to
give them in the future that's what this
is all about it's paying the taliban and
you know what i'll tell you ducey's
question was right on what you know
what's so great about this i mean you've
gotten you've got a taliban that
obama let out and and biden now is part
of the same drill by by closing bagram i
mean we were 20 years from 9 11 and were
in exactly the same place they hate us
just as much there's something tall to
kia that we all remember from years ago
which means they'll lie to us and we
believe it
except now they have 85 or whatever
billion dollars of our military
equipment and we're trying to be nice to
them how stupid are we yeah you know
geraldo bringing up the beau bergdahl
trade in which they we gave them their
entire taliban leadership is the lesson
here that we shouldn't be taking
prisoners now we just kill them we
because why keep prisoners if we're
going to let them go
well that is a provocative statement and
i uh you know we have a geneva
convention to prevent uh you know the
geneva
murder of uh of uh pows because we don't
want them to do it to us to our our
people oh you know i
i'm a
native born new yorker
what happened on 9 11 was something that
was very very personal to me it was
visceral it was horrible i see
janine nodding we you know it to be here
that whole span of all those decades and
then see your friends and neighbors get
murdered i hated the taliban i wanted
every one of them murdered i carried a
gun in afghanistan because i wanted to
kill them myself i said that i would
slit
bin laden's throat myself if i had the
chance
deep breath
and yet
they
it seems to me
generally speaking with the exceptions
that we all know about and suppressing a
demonstration here there and the rest of
it
they have basically kept their word the
taliban in terms of letting our people
go
the latest flight today 130 so to uh
to
doha and
i i believe that the the charter planes
in missouri sheriff will ultimately get
out there's insurance issues now and
there's a lot of but i think
right now
we did the right thing negotiating with
the taliban to get our people out
screwed up the evacuation but then
negotiated and the taliban have
basically kept their work but dana i
said this a million times the
negotiation is actually self-extortion
we advertised
our willingness to be extorted over the
health and safety of our because we
weren't going to go in there we just
will pay you not to hurt them in the
hasty retreat
they create you create a position where
now you are having to ask them
to be nice to you exactly instead of
saying true from the beginning
we're getting our people out you will
sit your rear ends down
and shut up until we tell you you can
get up
that's how you would do it but that's
not what happened
we may never know what is being given to
the taliban to get this and i just think
we should go back for one second
remember the rose garden ceremony where
bo bergdahl's father was there and susan
rice the national security adviser
called him an american hero yes and they
the taliban said in order for us to give
you this one guy you're one guy we would
like five of the enemy combatants from
gitmo and president obama was like okay
yeah yeah sure okay and um at the time
anthony blinken president obama and
others in the administration said
no one's gonna have to worry about these
guys we got it taken care of we'll make
sure that the situation mitigated and
here we are
guess what's going to happen on saturday
as we mark the 20th anniversary of al
qaeda knocking down the buildings
the flight 93 the pentagon they're going
to inaugurate their government that
includes four of the five of those enemy
combatants there you go and that's a
great reason why the country doesn't
trust joe with the vaccines because they
do dumb deals and then lie about it and
then it blows up in their face
joe biden's state department was
preventing americans from leaving the
taliban was preventing americans from
leaving maybe gensake's right they are
working well together joe biden actually
said this is a quote if there are
american citizens stranded there we are
going to stay until we get them out
another lie
these are all lies he actually brought
back refugees and
men with child brides from afghanistan
while he stranded americans think about
that and they probably weren't faxed
probably not
[Laughter]
they launched a drone strike said it
took out isis k it might have taken out
a family of 10. right lied about that
joe biden's on the phone with the
president of afghanistan telling the
president to lie and say things are
going great and maybe we'll give you
some more weapons and air cover if you
say that if you lie so i get political
cover
that president was impeached for that
name was donald trump
and he's checking his watch during the
coffins coming back
multiple times media is trying to cover
that up blows up the meeting with the
families of the fallen they're disgusted
with them because he's not connecting so
they walk out guys a joke right now
total joke hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else